II a sports it's in the game EA sports
it's in the game being on the man cover
was surreal me being able to school in
the videogame at anytime from anywhere
makes me wish I can do it in real life
he was the Bo Jackson you talked about
at that time PlayStation was so hot it
took me back to the Tecmo Bowl you know
when you think of tech mobile and all
the great players at a plate
everybody mentions one player that you
could not stop and that's Bo Jackson
everybody wanted to be Atlanta you know
because of it it was almost like a cheat
code so you know big up to the guys that
madman a they did a great job with that
in and it was real it wasn't something
that they made up it was something that
they see me do on the football field it
just translated over to the video game
he was the one that I know that
everybody from hip-hop was just like you
know so it's a big game on let's go and
wash it this can get our popcorn
let's get bit it was dope man it was a
dope experience for me to see a person
that I felt like represented us and he
could turn something into nothing that's
why we embrace him so much because we
did the exact same thing Atlanta was the
bed of hip-hop beautiful women it was
just the place you go to enjoy and Mike
was the face of Atlanta and to be honest
with you still is probably the face of
Allah
was almost at a time you couldn't shoot
a video and if Michael didn't have a
cameo in your video it wasn't too cool
of a video Vick did what he wanted to do
and that's what hip-hop is it's a form
of showing all we know that we all sat
there watch this me anymore Sunday and
we seen big awesome ass and we won't say
we gonna bust your ass like Michael Vick
it's just as a hip hop Atlanta the
success of the team they had us paying
attention so why y'all Penta team
remember big we don't sneak our music up
in it too
Michael Jordan was the greatest world
top but he was a hip hop well mike vick
was every young kids dream planning the
slums he was that relatable he made you
feel like you could play football
everything Mike did became a metaphor he
mother was I'm quick like Mike Vick you
know I'm saying everything that that
Mike did became a substance for somebody
artists to rap about he didn't change
who he was so the hip-hop community kind
of like gravitated today and then he
wanted to stay true to his boards he
wanted to keep the street credibility I
can make the similarity to Allen Iverson
with my country that was a point where
we are as a community or whatever we all
wanted to be like Allen Thomason there's
a point
to me like Michael Vick Vick comes from
an area whole Hampton Roads Virginia
Beach that area is one and which is a
lot of pride in athletes allen iverson
just to pick another guy iconic figure
just from that area there's a certain
defiance Mike didn't like talking to the
media
now I want to hear that question again
could be if I can throw up in the pocket
if I can make plays from the pocket
because I feel like I asked him so I
haven't want to hit out if you have a
job your job is to talk to the media
they were not of the mainstream or not
perceived to be of it and so that alone
gave Vick a certain anti-establishment
counterculture identity
you